there we go
we live we're live it worked now we just
have to react ummul ate all five of
those people who were in happy Halloween
people happy Halloween going on what's
going on peeps there's no one here
everyone's watching a light or live
right now ah we're competing with
Collider live we'll never win we'll
never win I heard some leaving Collider
hey Alejandro what son wants us may see
Kai's you King a TV studios late lego
marvel we got to see your costume dude
happy Halloween
Ireland Ireland Marlena
what's hey Marlena no happy Halloween to
you - thank you appreciate it
uh suck you crazy [ __ ] what's
up guys so is it is it past Halloween
for some you already all 24 hours ahead
we're gonna be here for like 20 to 30
minutes something like that we got some
[ __ ] to edit in whatever upload for
later happy Halloween to all of you guys
this is a real tattoo mm-hmm you just
gotta it's a real tattoo it's fresh as
you can see the tattoos having a hard
time sticking to my chest hair it's a
real pain in the ass now I think this is
the style hey della
how you doing but yeah we do have an
Instagram you could go to the link in
the banner of the channel mm-hmm
happy Diwali - come on guys let's get
some let's get some you know Halloween
questions going let's get some horrid
questions go and let's get 23 30 minutes
with us
Jamie Nikki what's winter is that real
it's very real so real you just got it
one thousand dollars this cost me I
spend so much money seven hours in the
chair favorite found footage film ooh
that's a good question never found
footage film - night
not on this night Jeremy Barbosa I would
guess I would have to say you know the
one that really scared me the most is
the most cliche answer that you can
possibly give was paranormal activity
that's good the [ __ ] out of me in the
theaters I don't know it's my favorite
movie but for sure out of all the yeah
found-footage movies I've seen that was
the one that terrified me maybe because
I've never seen a trailer or anything
like that you not knew nothing what to
expect if it counts I guess I would say
sinister because it's about to do the
guy who found the footage yeah but if I
had to go like pure I might go like The
Last Exorcism that movie always stick
with me favorite Michael Myers kill he
in Halloween too and Rob Zombie's he
stabs a dog to death only eats and then
he eats it yes it's something I've
always wanted to a Zack L I finished
daredevil season three last night I have
to hit up Andrew later today - hey Mike
I already got some Instagram messages
with that exact joke but I did finish
daredevil season 3 last night a play on
I got to get Andrew over here I want you
to review him know what was what was
your fare Halloween kill John that's
that's - yeah I was actually just gonna
point out the heats a dog in the
original film - yeah you know receded
Charlotte Adams s favorite part and
trick or treat I don't know my favorite
part is when my favorite story is
definitely the one with Sam and Brian
Cox at the end yeah I watched it just
yesterday with my lady and we she
enjoyed it she does she's gonna show me
hocus-pocus tonight I've never seen
hocus-pocus
oh it's a great yeah yeah favorite
Michael kill man um that's a really
tough this is live stream Sean we don't
have time I think about these man you've
got a dish these answers out I the
second you start answering ten more
questions come in anyway let's stay
quiet for a while
Jericho you never do explain that
Tehran's versus Myers busta rhymes all
the
Nick Hoover a reject nation what's your
favorite scary movie my favorite
actually you're quoting it's screaming
that's my favorite movie of all time and
my my favorite Halloween movie is
trick-or-treat John my favorite
Halloween movie is probably
trick-or-treat as well my favorite
horror movie tends to oscillate between
like the thing or the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre things pretty bomb and a lot of
things take not a fan first X Chainsaw
Massacre watch Texas Chainsaw - that's a
wild moving I've heard
I hope my lady let's go see my
girlfriend
does not want me to shave my chest here
you'll make it through the day and I'm
like I like I like doing stuff you know
with her so I didn't shave my chest hair
but this tattoo would stick so much
better yeah but I gotta keep her happy
but she doesn't like our faces somebody
asked insidious versus the conjuring I
personally prefer the sidious although I
guess the contrary would probably be
like a better film I prefer the
conjuring oh you mean like the the first
films I prefer insidious yeah but in
terms of franchise I prefer the
conjuring all right hey Lana sign has an
interesting question here if you could
make a scariest themed MCU film are you
doing hash tags get get some eyeballs
Nasri which film which characters would
you pick strange or Thor oh I would
definitely pick Doctor Strange but you
know what I I started watching blade
again last night I just watched like the
first 15 minutes and I completely forgot
the essence since it like first came out
and I completely forgot how hard are
that film is yeah and it's like kind of
corny it's got a cheesy like with the
whale blade he sticks up guys Harvey
Bullock from Gotham sixsome guy to the
wall and he goes but I feel like you
gotta bring blade back Billy it's the
perfect timing
let's bring the Marvel Zombies comic
books
Abby go on now it's about psy actually
buddy mind made a pretty sweet youtube
like you know homemade trailer for that
that made the viral rounds a little
while back
nice Jamie Jamie three extracts predator
versus Michael Myers Ryder girl that's a
competition somebody else did they above
asked like The Shining or or it was like
The Shining or something else like
completely different I was like
Halloween I was like they're not the
same at all oh where to go Adam make it
makes sent Magnus as what's your
favorite horror song - frame but mm-my
is a gory demise by creature feature Oh
creature feeds which you introduced me
to yeah yeah creature feature I guess I
might go with buried alive which is
their Edgar Allan Poe song I heard
creature feature it's like perfect
Halloween party music it's like you know
a bit macabre and goth but it's also not
too dark to be enjoyable and fun you
know do you know what uh was that
[ __ ] what says a goddamn song camera
with a song I don't know this is a great
live stream aterial okay I wanted to ask
satin in a coffin would you consider
that by Modest Mouse at horror song I'd
put that on a Halloween playlist yeah my
fun smooth getting blood on it is like
really dark yeah I need some dynamics
man plus that song has interesting kind
of grimy Tambor that's funny I listened
to in a way so so I put that on Holly
please write flux bucks says a beanie
way yeah this morning you hit the thing
that's that's the key with more than the
the police get an itchy
dude the fly Oh chuckles totally great
Charlotte Adams is running between this
live stream and the door for
trick-or-treaters you know I like never
see trick-or-treaters past few years I
never see a [ __ ] kid walking around
anywhere I'm trying to abduct so many
children it never have success Halloween
is not there oh they're on to you
they're wise they're like of course you
would try tonight
that
ass love from India Gregg and John well
if you see we do all our honest trailers
reaction for Batman the Animated Series
or cats doing something you will see
that some teases of my back rat
oh yeah the classic classic bad all
right
I'm a Dark Knight that John would you
leave out this time sorry sorry they're
always getting into his muffins there's
candy it's a closed bag of kid want rice
there you go another bag it's hard it
has no send a year living together he
doesn't realize bags didn't have no bags
okay they got into those cookies
yesterday I don't leave those out what
cookies the ones that David Laura house
patronage X David Waterhouse sentence I
have a lot of flip out when they do it I
just punch my kids all right let's see
here Casa de merica vs. mad mango says
why you guys don't do a reaction on
Netflix bird box movie looks like a good
kind of scary movie I don't know I'm
just now hearing about this thing there
was more time today I feeling they would
react more movies movie reactions
especially take a minute
Anthony Carey love you too buddy Lily
Patton I only know the first Chucky
movie sorry
first Chucky actually I wasn't super hot
on until I watched it again recently and
actually it's a very effective movie
John where's your costume
it's unless Jon's getting paid to be a
scarer a horror 19 dressed up I'm so bad
at coming up with costumes it's like the
last minute I'm like what's vaguely
spooky that I own I guess I'll be some
kind of stylish ghoul the big day I
gotta make the right choice Billy the
Kid Lawrence where's the collab with
totally jumb oh hey we wanted to shout
out totally jumbled on this live stream
did we did hope you dressed your
daughter up and she's a was like one now
right is a girl that means you got to
get her started with some [ __ ] ass
costumes totally jumbled I know you're
watching guys dressed funny girls
dressed sexy men
that sexy shoes I am I hope you showed
this message to your child totally
jumbled and one of our top patrons of
all times been around since the
beginning
make sure she dresses in something so
don't worry guys he laughs at these we
know that God and also I wanna shout out
Austin more often lost and more he has a
YouTube channel to serve fans zero seven
one seven does these Lego Star Wars fan
films isn't working then I say that
right yeah sorry somebody wrote Jason X
versus John Campea X criticized magic
can't be or like a weird metal failure a
good kill in that movie though that
nitrogen kill yet so I'm certain Austin
Hanks John I'm shouting out a patron mr.
fan 0 7 1 7 brickfilms guys you got to
go check out his channel seriously it's
awesome stuff I've seen I did a voice
work they still working on the short
film hahaha it'll eventually come out
but when it's out it's gonna be worth it
Nana I can't reveal who I'm playing in
it but it was a blast and he's working
on a bunch of cool fan stuff awesome
haven't talked in a while
hope you're watching buddy and this says
are you iron fist no where would you get
that impression James Bond or Mike
Flanagan
they're both quality it's very obvious
Mike Flanagan makes the more fun stuff
definitely I can't wait for anything to
do the next Fast and Furious really
deliberate Helene tuff says I'm gonna be
a [ __ ] rogue so it's true just don't
go out touching nobody yeah there for
there yeah you could be like the
metaphorical STD version for all of it
yeah you know uh ps4 pro is on its way
apparently I'm hoping it's maybe if
we're lucky it'll just show up I'm gonna
knock on the door while we're doing this
live
what does one more movie you would like
to see you remade psycho try it again
funhouse actually you know what I'm
doing the John finger thing you know
what in it's a good punctuation finger
wand it's a good lesson for the eye
Robin
I'm glad Greg is the reboot iron fist
and she you are the food and I this is
in support for iron fist to come back I
want it to return on the disney
streaming service and i am i am i will
be your Luke Cage yes perfect that's
what we've been eating all along as a
skinny white power call Tyrone and he
said I'm being racist like why you're
the perfect located black fur I think if
you've tried remaking psycho there's a
lot of people forget that psycho is
actually a franchise yeah the whole
franchise with a fairly dedicated
fanbase yeah bird ii was not so damn
Meryl screen junkies really vouchers for
psycho - I've heard cycling and the show
is pretty old a hyland a linear it's
raining in Texas
Halon a my texting girl and I think
psycho would work if it was based really
heavily on the book if you watch them
Cinna fix this video that really breaks
down the differences between psycho the
book and psycho the movie the various
very strange
ooh favorite horror remake I refine your
message I got some patreon messages to
reply to I know you're in there Lynette
don't worry I'll get back to you did it
favorite horror remake huh
favorite horror remake oh that's a good
question I just think the obvious answer
would be good for most people now I feel
like the old-school obvious answer is
just to go with either the thing or the
fly because those are the go to be like
these are good remakes don't say that
I'll remake suck example well I think if
you do like a body horror remake you can
make that better anything like the Hills
Have Eyes is a really good roommate
because that takes the original one it
makes it like way more [ __ ] of it's
like the the original Evil Dead I don't
sitter a body horror but a supernatural
or and then they do the rethink and they
make it like a body horror movie I
really like to remake a maniac maniac
sir that's a pretty good remake yeah
Halloween although I haven't seen the
original maniac so I can't yeah I can't
really this by like I've seen the one li
yeah we're just trying to get the ring
back into that one that Anne s asked you
hate Muslims know anybody except like
bad people we don't like that people
there's no one I hate we don't like
abuse or that for tyro and not agreeing
to do the Heroes for Hire up the ring is
a good horror remake yes ring oh yeah
the ring is a good one Tom Cruise says
you're hot and they jump in on couches I
haven't seen apocalypse yet I want to
yeah Sean
why do reaction is something if you're
not gonna watch the actual thing Sean it
takes who should have all the time in
the world watched only tear affectional
all you do is sit down and record not
write you don't never watch dogs and
[ __ ] nothing Leto works no time at all
happy Halloween to you too Julie you
know I gotta tell you guys I started I
was like you know apocalypse just came
out but I haven't seen cult and I like
to watch an order so I started called
[ __ ] hated that first episode and I'm
a huge American Horror Story Pat and I
have no interesting genuine cult and
because of that it's probably gonna
roadblock me to continue Blancas with
the clues that that I really watched the
first episode I couldn't stand it
Steppenwolf versus the house obvious is
that who's your favorite Iron Man gee
where's your Bohemian Rhapsody review
though let's see um it's not out yet in
two feeders so we didn't you get it
gonna be out on Saturday or Sunday one
of those two I got tickets for Friday
night because I really care about this
is like we're here to be questioned I'm
from LA I love all kinds of people I
have no issue with who you are any trans
people of course I have no husband
come on down transfer has caused some
controversy
I'm not Logan Paul ah yes I hate
suicidal Paul deserves to come back
according to the report does he already
it's been like five minutes ten months
and you guys pom first the spirit house
Tara candy whoppers Lord [ __ ] Coast
and jalapenos Oh actually I really want
to see that weirdly enough somebody said
right these Rob Zombie remakes are
getting out of control but I do feel
like if you had a restrained Rob Zombie
I would watch Rob Zombie psycho and I
know that everyone would hate me for
saying that but I don't care but I feel
like that could be a good [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you I am smack I did sign those
petitions I'm gonna make a petition to a
stop having petitions Hollywood most
ironic petition but I'll tell you I did
sign those two position
[Music]
Darius yeah I don't blame the Rob
Zombie's boy vampires uh have you seen
the first look of Henry Cavill as the
butcher yeah they're trying to do that
like Joker test footage thing huh what
I've done a video on it but I never
played The Witcher so the most leopard
you haven't played every video game
Rob's on row row row menem's comment
Grayson if the Tyrone Magnus V Greg LF I
were to occur
obviously claimed his victory no one can
defeat correct Greg is undefeated and
Greg will never lose yeah we'll see
about that
hey congrats on you eight-foot dick
badass
achievement the brick prints don't worry
Greg buy a porn star friend I too would
watch their porn that's a reference to
some video I earn I do that there were
no bells employed forgot about that
Lego no I'm not caught up on Gotham I'm
about to finish see someone at a patreon
we do the reaction watch along some we
don't binge watch them we do them one
Episode a week and we hover between was
the six different shows yeah so I mean
we finished some other ones but we have
everything six different shows and
Gotham is one of them and uh yeah
everyone told me wait till the second
season think often gets great I love the
first season I love it Oh favorite TV
specials and/or however I like the right
is dead Charlie Brown Great Pumpkin
Charlie Brown is when I pull out every
guy's we feed off the energy from what
you guys are saying in the comments I
also appreciate somebody said I love Rob
Zombie's music but his movies can be hit
or miss that's like the most even-handed
thing anybody's ever said about Rosa oh
favorite Pixar movie Venables incredible
I guess inside out maybe really I really
appreciate it with that so you want a
pain that could be my opinion Oh Jake
it's got the Dia de los Muertos like
that's nice I could be old man Danny red
you're right Deadshot because that's why
I have a hair I got the beard going I'm
Danny ran washed up tattoos falling off
his kid my favorite dreamworks animation
was flushed away dreamworks i like their
art man collab what do you think of the
eyre fish show canceling maybe you
should just watch the video that I
edited it's up on YouTube I am the
Winter Soldier I am Spartacus God asks
Greg why are some people racist because
they encountered a few people or their
parents taught them to be pretty good
town
information like hey I noticed a couple
of Armenians have set me
I hate all army they must all be the
same at all millions of you guys thanks
Walt winter production Tyler here you
are but I'm just talking about you know
we did not get the ps4 yet I hope in the
door like around this time we usually
get mail some hope it comes through
advice from Papa Craig that's very
general what if I said you uh would you
rather be a main character in DC foam or
a side character in the Marvel film a
main character they're just easy oh yeah
yeah cuz like a side character in a
Marvel movie you're gonna be like Cobie
Smulders you're gonna show up every now
and again so people can go oh yeah your
ass Oh Jay consol is 299 thanks dogs
Jake hey doing buddy that's your
favorite MCU Jake I'm always seen in the
comments thank you Jake I Love You Man
yeah I'll order you are a lovely cat
when are you guys going to make a movie
well actually I was talking with
Kristian harloff and we just got
greenlit a film about the red letter
media yeah and they're doing a story
about their letter media and Chris
Stockman having issues with each other
and Jeremy Jones is playing a supporting
character in it as yeah it's good these
kind of ideas you want to see a movie
doesn't stink choke whip you're
privileged 190 now you know that means
I'm getting my dark chocolate eminence
thanks with you oh you're awesome dude
Myles Jack was not doubt most overrated
movie like ever most up rated movie you
don't move anything's really overrated
[ __ ] Blair Witch Project I know you
do hate that [ __ ] yeah I said it makes a
live so I can't take it back yeah it's
in the ether now it's forever forever
besides Eminem oh well you know all the
legends atmosphere McLemore
take what GZ uh-huh
oh you know Machine Gun Kelly of course
oh hey no the ones who started it all
yeah man vanilla I use the og yeah yeah
who's gonna play Mike a rich they
playing themselves yes I like Danny
Brown lately I don't know Wilson
Kendrick what is D Alto Jones glad
coming I want it now want to collab with
real rejects today watch this trailer
this weird trailer so weird I haven't
watched Sabrina see the thing about
Sabrina's like I'm doing Riverdale on
patreon a half my brain it's like you'll
do reactions it was done the season 3 of
Riverdale just started so I don't know
yet I've been kind of on the fence about
when and how to start that because I'm
like if there's to be reactions I don't
want to spoil them but true truth truth
listen guys we're gonna spare here for
five more minutes alright five more
minutes
Cinco minutos are you guys gonna watch
the body movie maybe that's a big maybe
it's got the guy from American vandal in
it nice yes I want a bigger okay okay
your favorite honest trailers way back
when I feel bad because I love John
Bailey and I don't think he was the
honest truth on this one at the time but
whatever he doesn't write them I think
like way back when my favorite con is
trailer I think this I think is my
favorite because it's the one that
introduced me to honest trailers is the
Dark Knight Rises do another one who
really made me laughable I think that's
why its knowledge of their favorite
blade movie blade Trinity obviously I
really have appreciated the West
Anderson honest trailer I thought that
one that's a great rookie that's a yeah
do you guys like Chris Stockman
yeah I love Chris Tuchman man he's a
[ __ ] amazing critic dude who Jake
Gonzalez dude slow down on the Money
Train Laurie
I love your support and it's all really
you're a great guy I appreciate that
we'll take the money though ah when a
favorite music videos whoa wait a second
chick just paid money awesome or must
answer this question oh yeah that's the
way it works
I am Deadpool this Halloween what are
you going to dress like tonight a
trick-or-treat
well if I good for new training tonight
I'm obviously going with this outfit hey
buddy I'm obviously going with this
outfit today to copper you know the the
subscribers like to see you this is the
iron fist kitty right yeah and I don't
know John are you dressing up I'll
figure something out yeah I'll be a
really ragtag Snake Plissken I figured
out a perfect costume for myself the
other day and I can't remember what it
was now Oh what was letting you sing oh
she was asking what what my favorite
music videos were and I was trying to
narrow it down I mean one that always
comes to mind is go with the flow by
Queens of the Stone Age was really cool
like rotoscoped video where they're all
like these silhouettes with white eyes
and white teeth and it's all red and the
animations are really cool and then they
don't like there's some like really
creative michel gondry music videos out
there and stuff like that who is that
music video we saw where i [ __ ] bald
it sound like it's crazy like I love
like the Michael Jackson music videos a
hell of a lot but yeah I was you know I
remember fans the song turned down for
what but I loved the directed serving
but you know maybe I'm patreon start
reacting to my favorites Lynette because
there are some good ones out there I
gotta dig them up anything like you like
guerrillas always makes amazing music
videos because there in fact I'm always
fun that they didn't make rent store
nice for real but a story board
throughout this yeah yeah
add your snow ice make this clear right
here when I'll get this question in the
future monnet and I are still definitely
friends but Monnet is also someone who's
her she's more focused on other things
so going on YouTube videos not really
her priority
it's like a short film or something and
Breanna is kicking ass doing her own
thing right now she lives an hour away
so it's very hard to schedule a button
and of course obviously you can see
we've kind of reach Ange up a little bit
of the channel here tweaks in there so
yeah you know just having people come by
it's like we all usually once a week so
we can try to make sure we have at least
one video that I'll do well with them my
favorite Twilight movie is Eclipse yeah
Ethan Holgate it's a great question what
do you guys could do more trailers
revisited we need to we need to do work
for as long as it's been a long time and
I love doing those and remember we'll
just do all the horrible yes they
weren't the craziest abuse those videos
but I really did enjoy doing them so we
should do more yeah that ask Chris
stuffin or Jeremy Johnson for two I
watched both of them and they're for
very different reasons yeah totally i
watch I mean yeah I mean Jeremy Johnson
he's obviously snappy more funny one and
wanted to digest yeah and if you want
the in-depth you go to stuff you go
stuckman
let's see here did you get that tattoo
sure yes
where was it no we had not read to the
hizzy solo video favorite red letter
media via that is a blanket review I was
actually introducing them half in the
bag Batman V Superman review before I'll
ever watch the mr. blanket video and I
started watching this [ __ ] out of half
in the bed I love like I don't I am on
the side of the fence and loves the last
Jedi I hope there's more comments that
coming about that I myself as a who
loves last Jedi they they ripped that
movie apart I [ __ ] love that videos
to hold it up oh I think my favorite my
favorite Gorillaz album oscillates
between demon days or classic Beach but
I think it's Plastic Beach honestly and
if you're talking about the now now I
know now is really good it's like really
unified and it's very lean like I would
say humans and Evan no no I don't like a
lot I get why people were divided on
humans so I still find it compelling I I
wouldn't argue that either than now now
our humans is it classic but I think the
mounds actually really awesome that's
been like one of my main summer jams
lately I love that I love their take on
melancholy synth funk so neo reassess
what do you guys think about
scram grace Randall Wow it looks like a
video game here oh no Grace Randolph
it's not like I thought we deliver very
different opinions of a Grace Randolph
amazes me and how she's able to like
when you watch her videos and you know
it's like oftentimes we have trailers
that drop it like 6 a.m. our time and 9
a.m. hurt I think she's east coast yeah
and she's usually the one you like it
your race it like I said whatever she's
gonna kill us I'm gonna be on my average
she's gonna murder us abused no matter
what happens they forget their first but
it's like just this if this the find of
my computer's up first
usually gets herself first and
oftentimes she divides her reactions and
breakdowns in two different videos it's
so wildly impressive to me about her
videos is how I don't know she likes
scream recording and editing
simultaneously why she's how she's
talking it's it's very impressive as she
ascends was that SuperDuper quick and I
also like how her her movie reviews she
has like this broken down list so you
can kind of just skip through it to know
which part you want to check out I think
it's a really a really impressive style
that she has so let's talk about your
Tom Horne there Oh Brian Walters in
thank you so much buddy
sorry you just keep sure your $5 if I
don't know what you're talking about
they recommend us your favorite and we
can ambassador video yeah recommend us
your favorite and we will get started we
it's like I know I've seen yes in a
massacre
yeah and angry angry game nervous this
is a massacre I can't say what my
favorite is but yes that's the hard part
you know watch Boris in the massacre
that's what I just read 2.7 million
viewers he's doing alright okay good
Orion Walter s'en I love your name and
your profile photo it says say my
panties are melting right now damn thang
yes sexy guy right alright I always said
two five minutes that's what John and I
do we always say five minutes then we
stand here forever because these are a
sammich fan too much fun well how do we
get to always we can get back to the
chat oh my god guys we're losing you
losing you we should yeah almost like
hide user on this you how much I don't
want yeah I know pay five bucks and now
about to hide him from Africa there we
go can you wear an Iron Man costume for
Halloween you know the mask was like
fifty dollars and it's just not worth it
I'm talking alright I don't really watch
the nostalgia critic very much I should
I just sit on your Greek is so funny
okay we don't get enough you know we do
a lot of reactions and they're primarily
trailers and I live a few like YouTube
it is that we consistently check out a
youtubers but I'm telling you guys man
like other there's so many channels I
love that I just don't get to talk about
enough and this dominant critic is one
funny ass dude yeah I love blur blur
it's great what do you want to see
happen for venom two more M&M songs I
want a whole soundtrack by Eminem that's
what I want from ya Gator Martin or
Dustin and Wendy who that's a tough
don't make me Sophie's Choice right now
no choice right there I guess I would
have to uh sit with Dustin and Lindo
just Dustin all right that's a Wendy I
haven't Gator or what do you what he's
on my team Dustin don't get enough
credit yeah I cried and selects my
girlfriend when I found that what does
that mean someplace go to Google I
forget Matt relax you're about to watch
a reaction to learning a definition so
Plex is a more effect is an offensive
move using both professional and amber
fell back
yeah all right well I hope she and you
are both okay I guess I hope she's okay
first uh-huh her second is a lot of
people's modern-day Roger Ebert he was
on frickin Rotten Tomatoes before
everyone can get on we're gonna try and
get on this um are you guys childhood
friends when did you first meet no
actually we were put together by an
agency who are like you know you're a
good reactor you're a good reactor we're
going to put you guys together and you
know make a boy band idea John
auditioned I like this someone just
asked John or Greg I picked Greg I
picked John uh-huh do that ah
Jillian can't take her daughter
trick-or-treating that's [ __ ] so
they're going down a [ __ ] rogue outfit
yeah she can't daughters gonna be one of
them like put that in the subconscious
of her mind
well if she says then she's gonna
missile any pirates is like wait her
daughter that's what that says how did a
mom and daughter duo nice look how sexy
family which you saw was a cat that past
behind us are you ready for Captain
Marvel and aqua manages am definitely
not skipping them I'm ready for them now
I want the ball three in the same day
all right guys well it for reals well
making a solid forty minutes for a
thirty-six minutes and forty seconds
right now yeah just just nobody is
supposed to be correct dude could not be
more obvious huh a curly hair and a
green jacket and a tattoo of a dragon
have you guys watched DC Titans no but
I've heard it's great I might watch it
though I'm not in a rush to get around
it favorite double toasted video that's
[ __ ] hard to choose from it's so hard
to choose from the channel that has like
a bill yeah video who's yeah I mean back
when there was spill comm I used to
always listen to the Bucky Larson review
among many other things I would repeat
frequently I just saw something brie
Larson about white men
and she clarified I do not hate white
dudes what I don't know what you're
talking about
is that just the knee jerk is like if we
call for diversity you must hate white
people
what about Supernatural Season 14 guys
on our patreon we're watching
supernatural and we are on season 1
episode 11 episode 10 is going up today
yeah so after this I got a we got Clarke
and this ended it we got a no we have to
stay on so the Tyler I can see the ps4
arrive please please please oh
predators versus Greg I like that idea
perfect all right we got two minutes
here you guys make the most of it sweet
round of answer speed round speeding
around speed round
Bob others with Tyrone does in this
video Tyrone Tyrone in fact could have
any superpower tae road I would want the
ability I would want enough telepathy to
be able to like whenever somebody says
what was I gonna say then I can tell you
what you were gonna say but that's it
that's the superpower Yousef you said oh
my god Yousef were view big I haven't
seen you in forever yourself it has been
a minute and a half
never forget you oh we're gonna [ __ ]
have you been you sad guy go 45 minutes
on this oh dude I miss you two years
how are you what's new in your life
leave leave a comment fissures and awe
Youssef was in a really really to come
are you [ __ ] with me Bri mad that I
came out as Greg what are you have to do
you were really new really in a coma
you're not know this isn't a trick no we
can't hear your tone so we don't know
oh you class it's a very ed damn dude
I was nice now we have not seen Roma
heavy I know what John watches Roma the
Alejandro Oh peaky blinders
no skin Stimpy keep on guys I only watch
what will help the channel alright
favorite Tarantino movie I do love Kill
Bill Vol 1 a hell of a ton no mess
around real como what are you talking
about we said ha ha no do you mean no
Micah Youssef hit us up Shana Waker
predator those are comparable John wick
vs predators I want conjurer wants a
better film conjuring 2 scarier I'll say
that yeah I feel like I have more fun
with the conjuring 2 but Yusuf is that
real dude you said we first should we
gotta go I miss you man it's been a long
time so like a figurative coma where you
just didn't do a lot because you were so
depressed that you just didn't do much
Jon gets in that like four times a week
I have been there actually yeah versus
shot them I will win because we're just
gonna become friends alright guys we
really got a bounce we got some things
to edit a couple things to shoot expect
more videos tomorrow probably gonna put
up or JME Valente his request he asked
us to do a we put it off for so many
months but we had to eventually do it
because he was one of our top legs that
Bay drop there so long and what a better
time today for ought to watch along but
see you guys
much love it all you have a happy
Halloween be safe
girls her dressed up [ __ ] look out for
dangerous guys guys who think they're
funny don't beep herbs and have a good
Halloween and I did notice you Dutch
stone fanboy Tyler once that comes in
we're doing an unboxing video whole
patreon okay buddy believe it all right
love you guys we'll see you soon you
sure you want to hang your string not
yet let's keep going no let's just all
and Italy oh happy Halloween to you too
buddy
see you guys